Welcome.
Please confirm your name.
>> JP.
>> Full name.
>> JP Soucheck.
>> Please verify your identity.
>> Come on.
I just want to see Lilah.
>> What is your date of birth?
>> September 12th.
>> Father's middle name.
>> Peter.
>> Social security number.
>> Come on.
I just want to get through the door.
>> Please put your eye
next to the scanner.
Scare.
Mother of an Android.
>> Eye scan verified, you may entry.
>> JP, hey.
>> So
what's up with the whole door thing?
>> Well you know given
our recent trolling,
I really decided that I think
authentication is a priority for us.
We need to know what
user's identities are so
that we know that they
are who they say they are.
Anyways, I made these cool wire frames.
In fact, for version 0.3 of the app,
the developer and
I are going to work on the login flow.
Luckily, Firebase makes
authentication dead simple.
It has support for email login and
a bunch of other providers
such as Google login.
We're going to implement both.
And then, once we actually know who's
logged in, we can implement some cool
functionality, like letting users
signal that they bought items, or
that they're in the store shopping.
This will allow anyone looking at
the list to easily see things like,
Walter's in the store, or
that Kugare has bought cheesy flakes.
>> Right where do we start?
>> Hm, well I should actually continue
working on these login screens a little
bit, but maybe you can talk to
the developer about authentication.
>> Let's talk about authentication.